KOB white Chicago Bulls what's your
favorite NBA jersey you own besides your
team best sty Brooklyn Nets jersey if
you would go 1 V one with any celeb who
would it be Kevin
Hart if you could have a ticket to any
game in sports history what would it be
in why game five 2016 finals that's the
game Kyrie and Braun went crazy I would
want to see that in person if they were
to make a movie about your life who
would you want to play you bizel
Washington for sure who is the firstest
player in the league to guard Demar de
rozan what's your favorite NBA City to
play in besides home Toronto I like
playing Toronto cuz the fans the fans
are dope what is the last show you've
been suits if you could trade places
with one of your teammates for the day
who would it be Patrick Williams because
he's just like a cool dude he's always
chilled and I'm always up you could
build a Mount Rushmore of Chicago
athletes who would be on it dere Rose Mo
Cheeks Michael Jordan Patrick Kane yeah
for sure